what do you mean and this is my argument
this is my argument I've had with George
many times is how sometimes YouTube and
YouTube talent right is kind of bad for
show business what's why do you think
it's bad for your business because
animal I'm gonna say this because I
started when there was no internet
really so you know there was a way to do
things like if you wanted to get into
comedy rhymes there were these things
that you had to do what was there was a
way to do that I don't know I still
think it is this way I'm doing it yeah
yeah because Jay Gilbert's doing it
right and what it is is this is that you
okay I want to be a comedian
alright well I'm gonna have to just go
to a comedy club and work there which is
I did I got a job there I did open mic
dead it open mics all over San Diego and
then um I came to LA I lived out of my
trunk I got a job in LA at the Comedy
Store I started hosting the open mics in
Hollywood where I met a bunch of people
and then um in 2001 2000 I did Leno so
it took me 6 7 years to even get there
right and so that's the path that's
always been there right you either if
you want to do sketch you go to The
Groundlings Second City you know seven
years if you don't have to you do though
he's all about paying dues yeah I'm
about I'm about this it's about street
credibility all right so it's like
Bilborough might not like my stand-up
but he respects me so I think I think
that is the way to get great in front of
an audience
no nope no no no not this argument I've
been in these before I know you right
yeah I know you have okay okay here's my
argument okay okay is it that there are
things like there are bands that people
you know liked in the power
like Lee you mentioned Creed right and
there's a gigantic mass of people that
probably love Creed by their albums but
they're terrible right
and that's just that's that's just
terrible you compare Korea with
Radiohead would be absurd Radiohead are
just innovators their song structures
are weird and creative and they make
sometimes concept albums that just hit
the button in the right way you know and
you can't deny the okay computer even if
you're not a [ __ ] Radiohead fan isn't
an amazing album from beginning to end I
mean I've never unless you know do you
like that album
I'm not a big Radiohead fan okay well
but I do yeah I do respect them they're
good like they're why do you say that
whatever Isaac why do you say that
there's music and smart people like them
that's a people I respect musically like
a but to me it's like just because you
voted for Trump and you have the legal
right to it doesn't necessarily mean
that you're right you know I was gonna
do my like no you're stressing your
rhymes for you know but you're right New
Year's resolution for you Bobby is do
not talk politics but now I haven't even
talked about YouTube yet so okay what I
think like a lot of YouTube it's very
easy to make fun of on the surface and I
think it's it is a dip but it's a
different medium and if you look at how
hard any of the people in at work dude
they're always working okay it's they
know something different that's a
different thing they know how to
interact with an online audience they're
much more open with their fans there's
much more access to their fans you know
they're always on Instagram always on
Twitter always on they're always finding
the new things but would you say what
would be fair to say that there is a
large percentage of YouTube stars and
vloggers who are essentially kind of
talentless in our in our usual
definition of what talent is like
there's a reason I'm here right yeah
right so but I thought we just I just
for a second right
I know Britney furlong I think she's
talented I really do the vines are
yeah I know Kassem G I think he's very
talented and these two entities right
even if there was no internet no YouTube
would have made it I think one way or
now I have another friend manon mathews
who's like a vine Instagram person she's
very funny okay so I'm not taking away
from people I think there's very
talented they're talented people there
on YouTube but you also have the Afton
Gillian band right right so it's like
you have this just anyone can do it kind
of a thing and it just it no but it
saturates the market it I just think
that it's also harder if you have talent
to actually make it because there are
people that are on YouTube that have
millions of subscribers
right who are not talented they're
talented at one thing what like that
girl crying the other day I don't know
who that was who's that go Ryan which
one the one about crying about her
boyfriend and this oh the Sean the the
world I don't never heard of it but her
but she has it followers right she has
like a million followers what did you do
and her she's a lot I don't know what
I'm not very familiar with a YouTube
world but basically she outed her
boyfriend who's also YouTube personality
for being gay because somebody had taken
a snap of a snap of him kissing another
guy in a club I think I actually saw
this ironically because I was looking up
mukbang videos in English yeah yeah
and so this girl is getting millions of
hits for crying and apologizing to an ex
who she outed as gay yeah so yeah that
is all clickbait and her cleavage yeah
but it's also a different it's it's why
else are you gonna have that much access
to the the so called stars that they're
crying like having showing that much
emotion for you would you say I'm not
saying that's right
or vanity that's what the current
audience that demand is the younger
audience demands on a very personal
connect it's because those people get
auditions yeah yeah yeah because they
have more Twitter followers yeah that's
another thing and it [ __ ] us over
because they're not gonna book it cuz
they suck in acting but they have more
parties yeah
a director my buddy like that laid the
loogie he gets like he's a great
director but like hitting he gets
directing gigs over other people because
of his online following they'll ask you
for it because they're going to get
their money back regardless so if they
create a movie and they the people in it
have a large online following those
people are dedicated fans who are going
to buy the shitty movie regardless and
the company they get everyone gets their
money back yeah there is a glut of bad
movies getting put out because their
youtube stars huh yeah I mean look at
Gilbert I didn't know Gilbert right I
met him he can do a party of mine you
know I mean and she goes he's funny I
know what and then and then she know I
give him a chance and then when we did
this podcast he was the only one around
he that we had nothing to do with this
town in the beginning right and then
forth I went yeah I went god is this
gonna work
let's get somebody else but then he was
like pretty good right and then here's
how
Gilbert won me over when I said you
should do stand-up
he goes okay when I gave him a day he
showed up and he killed in front of
hundreds of people
a little hacky that doesn't matter for
him you can tell that he has you know
the talent yeah just net and that's what
I respect you know I respect guys that
like when I first saw Chris D'Elia do
stand-up I was there the third time he
ever went up oh wow yeah and he was
amazing
you can I mean it was not all there yet
but you could just tell that he has this
these balls and natural talent physical
talent to do it right and so it's you
know that's all I'm saying is is that
you go online and you see you have to
weed through thousands and thousands of
videos of people that shouldn't even
have a camera but you know we're now
Gilbert and I now in auditions for real
movies and TV shows with these people
right and so they take a place like that
you know what that laughs right there
that's like [ __ ]
cabinet laughing hey like he's up on the
cabinet laughing hey George new
resolution for you stop laughing all
right what do you think for instance
like okay so podcasting is relatively
new compared to actual like radio
broadcasting right and there's a lot of
radio people who really frown and I hate
it they hate us podcasting and they
think oh they don't have any
broadcasting chops they use fluff words
all day they don't get their point
across their [ __ ] and very amateurish
right but we're so I guess we have to
sort of it's different and there's it
trust me there's a sea of podcast I'm
gonna tell you why I can ought to tell
you [ __ ] why I can move on with that
and go because I've done all the ones I
haven't done I've never done Howard
Stern alright but I've done opening
Anthony about 20 times I've done Mancow
34 you know whenever I'm in Chicago
right I've done all the biggest radio
radio you know personalities throughout
the country right and let me tell you
this rarely am I in a situation where I
go oh my god these guys are so good and
they're above my pay grade or whatever
usually I go in going yeah I got this
and I'm controlling the [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah right and also I feel like I've
done enough throughout my whole 20 years
that I you know that I can justify why I
can do a [ __ ] podcast okay and that's
that's my proof all right so what [ __ ]
broadcast [ __ ] radio what no I I'm
saying I'm drawing a parallel here where
as you know you know actors or people
like you who went the traditional route
are looking down on this isn't radio
though lady
I know it's free content just listen
even that it's no it's not even that
it's like radio you deal with you know
unless you're on like Sirius or whatever
regular regular radio you can't swear
you keep dirt there's music being played
right even if they have a morning show
they still have to integrate music and
commercials
and it's pretty much like like saying
Jimmy Fallon is comedy it is but it's
comedy for families it's not like Sasha
Baron Cohen when he did the ologies show
comedy that's real to me real comedy
yeah made me laugh like that other show
the other night when you're watching an
English show I don't know anything about
it I know that's funny
hilarious it's called chewing gum the
main actress her name is Mick Mikayla
Cole or something like that she it is
even just the first episode alone Bobby
and I were crying yeah it was so funny
and you turn it on you she goes she was
laughing I was late at night I go what
are you laughing at it's probably
something dumb so I looked over and
watched to see what her and as soon as I
saw one scene I just go you know what
that I already know that that's good
yeah that's good you can just tell yeah
you know you can tell and so you know
like I said I'm fans of and friends with
a lot of youtubers you know and um but
you don't necessarily like me either
you think Timothy DeLaGhetto likes me
know that get your pen up vulture tell
me why doing some weird cuz you go all
out for your comedy I missed the early
days of maker when you were like eating
people dudes ass cheeks and stuff
there's some mythical music video that I
was like two weeks before I got there
and I everybody's like yeah Bobby Lee
can eat my ass I asked for comedy power
it took me two months to see Bobby's
dick you know everybody else is like yep
you came and got naked and I'm like no I
don't show my dick to people that I
think are gonna want it
honestly like are you like Gilbert how
many times have I shown you my penis the
first that was a comfort about it what
is how many times I've so many times no
not that much three yeah that's not a
lot the kind of relationship you I think
that you wanted to I don't know I don't
know what you're laughing but but
Georgia I never shown me you my dick
because you think he wants it no I just
don't like his little white judgment on
it oh my dick six inches or whatever no
it's just like this like he's from I
want to talk about your church
[Music]